Hello and welcome, everyone. It's
January 11, 2023. We're in ActInf
Livestream number 1.1 on governing
continuous transformation. Off to the
facilitator. All right,
so today we are discussing Parr one, a
Governing Continuous Transformation.
We're looking enough to have the author,
Bijan Kezeri, with us today. I hope I
pronounce that right, Bijan? Yeah. All
right, wonderful. So we are the active
inference institute. So we are
participatory online institute that is
communicating, learning, and practicing
applied active inference. All those
links are socials, so this is recorded
in an archived live stream. So please
give us feedback so we can improve our
work. All backgrounds and perspectives
are welcome, and we will be doing our
best to follow video etiquette for this
live stream. All right, so this
is all active coherence activity are
participatory, so if you want to get
involved, let us know.
All right, so this is the one dot one
book stream. So we've been discussing
governing continuous transformation,
reframing the strategy governance.
Conversation by John Kasri So we've
over the past four live streams, we've
been discussing part one of the book
section by section, and it's Beren very
methodical unpacking the concepts. And
today we're lucky enough to have Bijan
with us in person, where we're going to
be actually kind of unpacking some of
those hairy concepts or questions that
came up during those previous four
livestreams. So if you haven't seen
those previous four live streams,
definitely recommend watching those or
better yet, reading the book, and that
will give you some important context.
All right, let's go into it. So before
we get started, let's just do some quick
intros so I can start this off. So let's
do an intro, and then quickly just say
what you're excited about today. All
right, so my name is Tyler.
I work in Dow governance and protocol
design. In a previous life, I also was a
strategy consultant at large
correlation. So organizational change is
something I'm very personally passionate
about, and I'm really excited to kind of
dive into some of these thornier
questions that came up over the previous
four livestreams and very happy to have
John with us here today. I'll pass it
off to Bleu.
Bleu Knight. I am an independent
research consultant in New Mexico. My
background is largely neuroscience, but
I am a founding member and on the board
of directors here at the Active
Inference institute. So I'm very excited
to kind of get the perspective of free
energy governance. Like, we are the
active inference institute. We should be
using free energy governance in the way
that we kind of drive our institute
forward with our board and our
governance methods. So I'm excited to
just be studying this concept and
learning how to best apply it to my work
here at the institute. And I'll pass it
off to Daniel. Hey, I'm Daniel. I'm a
researcher in California. Looking
forward to the conversation today to
continuing to develop our relationship
with the work and just to check in
periodically as the niche continues
to develop so rapidly, which is a focus
of free energy governance. So, Bijan to
you. Okay, so I should address the very
same questions.
Well, obviously in life
everything is very past dependent. So I
happen to actually, at a very young age,
go on the board of directors of public
companies. And as a result of
it, I was always fascinated actually how
companies are being governed.
And I was many times also astonished
about the fact how disconnect at the
very top of the company, where all the
decision power resides, is disconnected
actually from
the frontline of the company. I do
recall actually one of the boards I
have joined in 2019. Very exciting
company, Tsuka. It's a difficult name to
pronounce, but it's a Global leader in
innovation services. We do really
fascinating projects around the world.
And when I introduced myself, I said
this really all the intelligence in a
firm is really at the bottom, it's not
at the top. So that was obviously very
surprising for board members to listen
to because the very self understanding
of board members is that they are the
smartest guys in the room and that they
obviously are entrusted by the
stakeholders with allocating all the
resources. So I'm really excited about
how the role of the board has to
change in a world which is, and has
become increasingly discontinuous, very
distributed, where a bunch of very smart
guys meeting up four to eight times a
year to take all the key decisions in
a company, is not, in my view,
a recipe for sustainable success. And
that has obviously led to the fact that
many times CEOs become very powerful
and the board is there to guide, to
advice, to approve and to make sure
kind of things are more or less in
order. But I think, like with
everything, with every person, with
every process, it's a little bit like
flipping the coin. I mean, as much as
certain things or certain people explain
success, they eventually also explain
failure. And the idea really
behind the free energy governance
concept, and inspired obviously by
Calfriston's free energy principle is
when you look at biology, you look at
nature, you start understanding
there's a lot of self organizing
mechanisms which determine the survival
of an organism. And my idea
and the drive behind free
energy governance is really we should be
revisiting a number of self organizing
principles to make the company actually
much more resilient in
discontinuous and distributed market
environments.
I'm just looking at the questions, the
other questions. I mean, that's
certainly something I'm excited about
that's in a nutshell, really what has
been inspiring from my background and
from a theoretical point of view, the
free energy governance concept.
And I do think and that's why I'm
looking really forward to this session
and I really appreciate the diligence
with which you have prepared it and the
questions that when I talk about
the free energy governance concept,
people get it because there's really
three simple dimensions. There is a
structural dimension which very strongly
inspired from neurosciences, but how do
we connect actually our prefrontal
cortex with the nervous system? And how
is it an interactive, top down, bottom
up connectivity which has to work. And
you can transpose this onto
organizations, and you can very quickly
see there's tremendous friction in an
organization because the bottom and the
top don't really interact
and connect the way our nervous system
and our brain does. The second dimension
is dimension I call cognition. But what
it really means is rather than teaching
adaptation, which is really the dominant
school MBA programs,
we should be analyzing the environment
and then adapt accordingly. I say the
world and strategy is not environment
driven, but it's interpretation driven.
So when you take a more interpretation
driven approach, you are much more in
power to create actually your own.
I. Don'T like the word reality because
that's a very relative concept, but you
create your own eco niche and the
Econiche you really want to compete in.
So I do belief we are much more in power
than we resist to belief. And the third
dimension is related to capabilities.
And capabilities is a big
topic in management science. Obviously,
capabilities at the board level haven't
been really addressed. And my work on
the free energy governance side is
trying to develop capabilities at the
board level and certain meta
capabilities. And that really leads into
the topic when we say in the distributed
and continuum world, how does the board
has to evolve in order to be meaningful?
It's either going to be complexity,
irrelevant, it could be potentially a
source of inertia, or it can allow
the company to prosper and to outperform
its competitors. I guess for this slide,
I wouldn't say much more.
Awesome. There's a lot to dig into
there. And so we'll get to some of those
bigger topics in a second. Beren all
right, so this is where we're at in the
book. We've been reading part one up to
now. It's a lot about framing the
conversation about what free energy
governance is and the free energy
principle. And right now we're at the
conclusion. So we'll read the abstract
for that in a second here.
All right, so the room app for today.
Today is a discussion around these seven
questions. And the beginning of the
discussion will be talking more about
like, really how do you communicate what
free energy governance is? And then
later in the discussion, we'll be really
more getting into some of the nitty
gritty questions about maybe some of the
implication of what free energy
governance can look like. And we'll keep
it free flowing today. I mean, we'll try
to get all to all these questions. If we
get off on the tangent, that's actually
totally fine. And we can just kind of
take the conversation where it goes.
Very good.
Sorry. We'll start off by reading the
abstract, and then we'll kind of get
into the discussion. But is there
something that you want to say before we
move on? No, I follow you.
Okay, great. So, Bleu, do you want to
read the slide for us? Sure. Is that all
that's on the slide? No, there's one
more. Okay. Strategic renewal research
is now confronted with important
challenges concerning process design,
cognition, and dynamic capabilities.
Sensing and sense making of relevant
signals as a basis for initiating
strategic renewal are preceded by an
action centric and explorative
engagement with the world. We are moving
from coaligning organization with
environment in form of adaptation to co
creation. As firms build agility through
distinctive environmental enactment.
All existing frameworks and studies in
corporate governance as well as
strategic cognition remain characterized
by one or a communication of the
following fundamental limitations.
Cool. I could take this slide. So, one,
the environment and environmental change
are generally treated as objective
reality. Two, strategic renewals treated
as a top down content rather than top
down bottom up process challenge.
Strategic renewal is studied at the
managerial level, but only marginally at
the board level. Formal processes are
the focal unit of analysis, and five,
demographic and universally measurable
variables dominate with no due
conversation. For strategy relevant meta
capabilities. At the board level,
reentry governance introduces a novel
crosshair called generative coherence
centric framework, empowering the firm
as a generative model of its eco niche.
Shareholders and board directors must
interpret the board's strategic
relevance in a discontinuous world. If
not, the board is prone to turn into or
remain a source of inertia compromising
firm performance and survival.
All right, let's get into it.
So first question here is just free
energy governance. As we've been going
through this last four live streams,
it can get very deep, right? There's
like a thermodynamic angle to it.
There's an information theory angle.
There's a machine learning angle,
right? So you can go down the rabbit
hole, and you can go very far. But the
end of the day, too, there's a very
intuitive way you can think about free
energy governance. And so I'm curious,
when you meet executives, other business
leaders, and you have to communicate
what free energy governance and the free
energy principle are, how do you
succinctly communicate that
communication? Hey, this is different
from what you're already doing. When you
look ant what has been
happening in the last 2030 years,
we see that technology
is not only building incredible
connections, but we also do see that the
cost of innovation is coming quite
dramatically down. If you take a start
up in Silicon Valley in the 1990s
to build something that, say, which
would take a million dollars at the
time, you can probably do it today with
$10,000, the same thing.
So the power of the individual in
creating new stuff, changing the way we
consume product wise,
chaos increased dramatically as a result
of it, this continuity has been rising
dramatically. Apart from that, the world
has obviously also, again, thanks to
technology, become quite connected
and integrated. Now, when you look at
all that stuff, what technology is
doing, what individuals are doing, they
don't even need to be incorporated.
It's creating a lot of change in the
resource market. And the resource market
is really actually,
I do not like the term top and bottom.
Probably the bottom certainly is much
more front line. The top, yes,
usually the top is the board because
these are the last guys, the ultimate
people taking actually the resource
allocation decision on big topics which
concern the entire firm. But when you
look at all the stuff that
is happening right now in product
markets, in supply Heins in
universities where there
is great thinking, there's not only
great ideas, there's new products coming
out. And you start looking at the guys
who are sitting in the board of a big
company they are so far removed from
really, Heins connected to what can
happen. And that's very natural because
there's only as much attention we have,
as much cognitive bandwidth we have and
how much can they process. The bigger
problem, however, is, and I would say to
your first question, what's the hook is
every board member, every CEO would
love. And there's a
wonderful concept which is called
skilled incompetence. And skilled
incompetence really means people are
doing actions which are
counterproductive to what they really
want to achieve. And clevel
board members are really keen on
understanding what's happening in all
these markets and catching up on all
the impulses, inspiration in order to
think about where should our
organization be going? But inadvertently
they are creating a lot of friction and
they're bringing themselves far more
removed. So the big challenge, and this
is really what free energy governance is
addressing, how can we connect the top
ant the bottom in a much more efficient
way? And that has a lot of challenges
because you have middle management,
house information, traveling. But a much
more interesting thing is, which is
happening right now, is when you look at
artificial intelligence. Artificial
intelligence effectively allows
you to decouple two things which
usually came as a unity. It is the
prediction and the judgment which
together form a decision. So when you
look at the anatomy of a decision
consisting of prediction and of
judgment, with the increasing deployment
of artificial intelligence that is being
actually decoupled. Now,
what that means is that the value of
human judgment becomes much more
important. But then the question does
arise who is best positioned to make the
judgment? Is it really the sea level?
Is it at the very top? Once I have all
the AI prediction available and I can
generate great predictions as an input
into my decisionmaking and subjected to
judgment. So all of a sudden you have to
very carefully think what should be and
continue to be decided at the very top
and what should be not reached the top
any longer because it's taking too long,
it's creating too much friction. And
maybe the board of directors in the sea
level are no longer best positioned to
decide on many things they're deciding
on today. So I think what we will be
seeing in the next decade to come and
it's partly driven by technology, but in
particularly driven by AI technologies,
that there's going to be a shift in
power where and how decisions are going
to be taken. And we will look at
organizations, the way they are run
today, the way they are structured
today, they look like a dinosaur because
they are not really connected to
what is happening really in the
marketplace in real time. So the C level
is facing a big challenge of A,
how they're connecting to the bottom and
how the information is flowing as a
basis for them to take great decisions.
Second, decision power is probably
becoming, within an organization also
more attributes. So it's not going to be
as centralized as it used to be. And the
more important thing is, and this is
very fundamental to free energy
governance is communication. When you
look into companies, Coda and
even companies where I'm on the board
of, it's frightening to see how
communication is a real problem.
Everybody has the best intentions, to be
clear, to be transparent, but
communicating is many times also a
question of Lagrange. And if we
do believe that in the future the
interface between the machine and the
human is going to be increasingly
important, we need to develop a language
which allows us to much better connect
to the machine. And that's where I
believe the free energy governance
framework, which is built on the free
energy principle, which is all about
prediction errors minimization. When you
start putting actually prediction and
prediction models at the center of what
it is about to run an organization,
take Active Inference Lab Institute,
you what is your prediction model? You
do have a prediction model which is
actually your world model. And on a
daily basis you are generating
predictions about what you think should
happen, what is likely to happen, what
interests the audience. These are action
prediction you are generating and
eventually this team, you guys are
applying your best judgment of what
you're doing. Many times you're testing
the predictions and the predictions may
actually give you feedback which tell
you you shouldn't be doing this. So
eventually your judgment will really
matter. But what you do
when you start adopting a language of
prediction error minimization, I believe
you become much more performing because
what you start doing in a much more
conscious way, you start measuring the
performance of your individual
predictions, which eventually feed
your decisions on the basis of your very
judgment. And over time your judgment
improves as well because your testing
and your measuring of performance of
predictions is getting better. And when
you do this and in my book, in a later
part of the book, when I've been trying
to relay a very theoretical
concept more to the world of practice,
I've been looking at the budgeting
process. The budgeting process is a
great domain where
you have to make a projection, a
prediction about next year and
you make this prediction on facing
actually two fundamental questions what
is you control, what you don't control?
What is what you know and
what you don't know? So there's a lot of
unknowns you have to deal with. And when
I'm looking at the budgeting process,
I'm dealing with a lot of unknowns.
What is really critical for me is not
the number people put behind that
unknown but it's the process they
suggest of how they turn the unknown
into a known. And it always starts with
very small steps. So I think
organizations need to start
communicating much more in terms of
prediction models, in predictions,
falsifying those, confirming those.
And when you start articulating
a strategy or a vision you have as
a prediction model and that there are
predictions generative by that
prediction model and you empower the
organization through great and clear
communication to challenge your
predictions. You're creating a very
different culture of how you engage the
front line with the key decision makers
who at the end of the day, of course,
there is always a small number of people
who are accountable for managing and
allocating the resources of a firm.
So I think that's a critical hook
because a
lot of sea level people and board
members talk about uncertainty.
But here's a really critical thing.
First of all, uncertainty is a very
subjective concept. What your
uncertainty is may not be mine or vice
versa. So in my view, when somebody
says the world is uncertain or
unpredictable, I mean, we all agree
there is a lot of things we don't know
what's going to happen tomorrow. So in
that regard there's many, many worlds
that could appear. In that regard, yes,
there is some degree of
unpredictability. But if I talk about
uncertainty, of course
there is uncertainty. But at the
end, using uncertainty and
unpredictability is really just an
admission of the very limitations of my
world model because uncertainty
is an incredibly rich training ground
for my predictions to eliminate and
reduce uncertainty and turn unknowns
into knows. And when you look at
organizations and I think sometimes most
of the time, sea level and board level
are not aware of the fact the further
you go down in the organization to the
front line, they have much more
intelligence and understand much better
how rules are creating the source of
inertia and actually masking and
burying uncertainty and don't make it
available for prediction testing and
ultimately better decision making. So
our challenge in today's world with a
lot of discontinuity, a lot of change
happening for very understandable
reasons because the individual has more
power. We have cheaper technologies
available to create much more impact.
We need to embrace uncertainty. We
should not avoid uncertainty. And today
the organizational frameworks are not in
place to allow organizations to embrace
uncertainty because they don't know how
to talk in prediction and prediction
models and test those predictions. I'm
sorry, Bleu.
Sorry, I thought you were wrapping up.
I just wanted to just ask a quick follow
up question. Can you clarify what you
mean by discontinuity or continuum? I
mean, I think I have an idea, but I
would just like to maybe have a more
clear I try. To avoid
the word disruptive,
but when you look at and you look in
management science, Clayton Christian's
disruptive technology, which is not
necessarily radical technology, it's
technologies that can
change, for example, a cost factor.
And the cost factor is so decisive that
all of a sudden it changes the way
business is being done and what is being
deployed and whether you're still
shipping something or you're not
shipping something or whether you
could argue to some degree.
Let's put the particular context of the
pandemic aside, but a valid
question is the way teams
and zoom have become
so much part of our day to day
engagement? I have been someone who
has always preferred the physical touch
point, and in my own company I have
offices in different parts and
my approach has always been I'm going to
be physically present in those offices
at least once a month as I tour them.
I've changed this radically. The
pandemic is over, so I definitely
don't buy as many flight tickets
any longer. And this is
not a strong example, but I do think
that a lot of airlines struggle with the
fact that business travelers are not
there the way they're there. There may
be more recreational travelers and the
planes continue to be packed, but
there's less planes. We shouldn't forget
that either. So has video calling and
created actually some discontinuity on a
massive scale that can disrupt
industries. So you do have these
kind of discontinuities. They don't need
to be radical innovations, but they
change on a massive scale the way things
are being done. And there's obviously a
lot of examples that happen all the time
that happens sometimes which are beyond
what we can see, but there's a lot of
stuff which is happening behind the
scenes where things are so radically
changed that companies are from one day
to the next out of business.
And I guess that's what I mean with
discontinuity more in the term in view
of disruption, but I don't like the term
of disruption. That makes sense.
And I think just to unless you have more
you want to give on this elevator pitch.
But I think to kind of summarize what I
think you're saying, or the essence of
my takeaway is you're really putting
uncertainty at the heart of the
organization rather than something that
is to be worried about, to be anxious
about you're really saying, hey, this is
an intrinsic part of being an
organization, having a world model.
There's nothing we can do about
uncertainty, but we can manage it. And
we can do that by making prediction
error as really the heart of how our
organization thinks about its business.
Absolutely. And this comes back to
active inference lab instituted because
the most important word
in active inference is active because
you put action at the center of what you
do and it's the actions that create your
perceptions and not the other way
around. And that's a fundamental thing.
And you go into the sea level, they
still do believe that they perceive and
then they act. And that's terrible
because then you are really a victim of
whatever is happening outside your
control and the power of the free energy
governance framework and obviously the
free, free energy principle that you get
actually into control and the way you
work yourself through to reduce the
unknowns and you can only do this
through the actions.
And there was one question you had on
the first slide, which I think was
question number six, we don't have to go
back there. But it was related to
Silicon Valley. And when you look at
the smaller a company is, when you take
a startup business, a startup business
usually does not have the challenge of
top down, bottom up, because there's
three guys sitting in a room and they
wear many, many hats at the same time.
All they do share is one purpose, one
mission and one big dream. As a
result of it, almost in a self
organizing way, all the right actions
will fall into place because the goal is
so clear of what they want to achieve.
The problems start, when the team starts
growing, when things are being
delegated, when all of a sudden
communication becomes important, when
all of a sudden there is a distance
between where the action is happening in
the field and the person making the
decisions about how financing is being
raised, how it's being allocated and
what story is being told. So when
you look at the very mature companies
in silicon valley and those who have
been successful and have kind of shaped
a big part of our life in the last 1020
years, you look at an uber, you look at
a facebook, you look at a Google is
because these companies stayed actually
very true to their core. And you can
look at that. They fulfill all three
dimensions of the free energy governance
framework. They make sure the way they
organize, that a lot of decision power
is actually ant the bottom. They are not
big fans of pulling all the power to the
top. They want to make sure that
individual entities can work, operate
the side and be very agile and very
fast. So that's already the first
element, the structural element, how you
connect the top and the bottom. Second
element is the cognition part.
Neither Google nor Uber. Noor Facebook.
Any of these companies are doing market
research when they really started with
what they want to do as business to
figure out is there a market or
whatever, they create something which
they enact, driven by a deep passion,
many times a deep passion of believing
this is how the world should work. We
will adapt the world to us. It's not us
adapting to the world. And that is what
makes these companies incredibly strong
because they're creating their own eco
niches. When you look at the iPhone
coming out in 2007, everybody was
mocking it. BlackBerry, which some of
you may not know even at the time, but
was the dominant communication device
because it had a great keyboard and all
of this to have a phone without a
keyboard, with every disadvantage,
low battery, which was literally putting
everything together, but everything was
really sub optimal, one didn't give it
much chance. But what effectively
at the time, Steve Jobs as the visionary
or representative of that vision for
whole team articulated was the
phone will be a computer and it will be
a computer that can actually do anything
and you have it in your pocket. And that
was a tremendous vision and Nokia didn't
have that vision and they focused on the
prime functionalities. So I think what
these companies do is and that's the
second dimension of the free energy
governance framework, they really enact
their own environment. And the third
one, which is related to capabilities in
the free energy framework is and I
have related to this in
the free energy governance framework in
my book. I try to be very specific, but
the capabilities part I focus on is how
and I'm always focusing capabilities on
the board level. And on the board level
I look at how you manage duality and
in business there is two sets of
dualities which explain everything.
These are the two fundamental sets and
only those two sets. The one is how do
you manage simultaneously exploitation
and exploration. You have to manage your
existing business and optimize it and
take that cash flow which is available
and you have to work on the future cash
flow which doesn't exist yet, you don't
have the products yet and you have to
find a way which is very challenging.
Lots of books have been written about it
of how you manage these two things in
parallel. In the meantime, my view is
these things happen actually almost at
once on top of each other, rather than
being two separate organizations. But
there are many different views also
depending on the maturity of the
company, the life cycle of the company,
what is the better approach? That's the
first set. So first set between
exploitation of today's cash flow and
developing through exploration
tomorrow's cash flow. The second set is
a very important one is the trade off or
the. Duality between financial
control and strategic control.
Financial control in this context means
M and A, how you buy other companies,
which you're not doing in house to
accelerate and to move forward.
Strategic control is really in house
innovation. So a company and a board is
continuously challenged. Is there a
sustainable balance between in house
innovation and external innovation?
Or M and A doesn't always have to be
about innovation. It could be market
share with geographic
expansion. But what is really important
to understand when a company relies
too much on financial
control, m and A, its survival gets
really threatened because the more
companies you buy, the more over a
period of time your in house capability
to innovate will weaken and effectively
you're losing your strategic control.
Now coming back to the Silicon Valley
companies, what they have done
tremendously successful, whether it's
Mehta, Facebook, Google, they have
been continuously investing, they have
been the biggest investor as a
percentage share of their revenues.
They have invested in R and D, but at
the same time they buy a company every
month. So they keep this balance in
an incredible way. And that is in
my view, a tremendous capability for a
company to keep that balance. Don't
allow it going one way, but keep that
balance. So when you look at the free
energy governance framework, looking at
really Silicon Valley as a startup, the
question doesn't even arise because
everybody is sitting in one room. Now
you take this massive company, some of
them are the biggest companies in the
world, like Apple and so on. They have
mastered it, in my view, by not
being obsessed of how the top has to
control everything, understanding that
we are much more powerful as an
organization if the unknowns are
being turned into knowns and that those
who are capable of doing it are
empowered. And they're usually much
closer to the resource markets,
suppliers, technologies, clients in
order to do so. So I do think in
those companies you find many facets of
it which make it very successful and I'm
very convinced that they are also the
next companies who are embracing
artificial intelligence as a way of
changing again how organizations are
structured, how they take decisions and
how the power may be shifting.
And that was one of the questions you
asked me, which is on the slide is
why being so obsessed with the board?
Actually, I'm not obsessed with the
board as such, but the reality is that
the board, depending on the
role of the board, varies many times
from countries, from jurisdictions,
culture, what role they play. But when
you look at a typical board,
the CEO may be on the board. In the US.
The CEO usually is on the board. The CEO
is actually usually also the chairman.
In the rest of the world they strictly
separate these two role, CEO and
chairman. But you will have the majority
of the board members being nonexecutives
and these nonexecutives have no role in
the DayToday operation of the business.
But they come and they leverage the
expertise from different industries and
overall their experience they
have accumulated over usually a longer
career. And the board,
because it is not executive, is in
my view uniquely positioned not
to get involved in the content
dimensions of the business. The board
can't tell you you should be buying
this, you should be doing this. What the
board should be doing is to ensure that
we have a process that allows for
free energy governance to come to life
bottom and top, properly connected
articulating prediction models, having
the right language, articulating
predictions and empowering the rest of
the organization to challenge those
predictions. And the third one is where
the board has to self evaluate are we
really keeping a good balance between
strategic control and financial control?
And these are a role which in my view
cannot be delegated to the CEO and needs
to come actually from a meta organ which
literally the board is to ensure those
processes and just make sure that they
are in place and that they stay alive.
That makes sense if I understand you
correctly. It's not to say that a board
is like intrinsically a part of free
energy governance but like we have
inherited these legal structures where
oftentimes for nonprofits and c corpse
you need to have a board so you might as
well put it to good use. And a nice
attribute of a board is that it's
separate from the rest of the
organization and that means you can play
this kind of unique and special role in
free energy governance. Does that
characterize what you're saying
correctly? Absolutely. And if you look
at the Dow, I mean effectively it's a
software and it's a contracting, I mean
a smart contracting in a certain way.
So what you should be doing, you should
be because in the Dow the governance
dimension is not about content. I mean
it's not about saying you should be
going left, you should be going right.
The real question is are you following
the right process when certain things
should happen or they shouldn't happen?
And that in my view is for
a board should be the guardian
of institutionalizing
and of keeping alive self organizing
mechanisms as I described them with the
free energy governance framework. And I
think in a Dow you may actually write
this into the software. The way those
things it's, the language, the
communication, the way actually what
information can actually take decisions
and has the. Right judgment that makes
sense? I'm actually curious. This might
be a hard question. I think part of the
reason it's hard because it's very
contextually dependent but I'm wondering
if you could have your pick up like a
different governance structure, right?
Maybe it's not the board but something
else that would be more fine tuned and
appropriate for free energy governance.
And like you can have any legal
structure you wanted? Are there things
that you would change about the board?
Or maybe it's like just not the board at
all. It's a different kind of entity
that you would think would be more
appropriate for free energy governance.
I do think that
the power of the board. And if
you think about it, it's funny. Now,
historically, it was never one person
aboard. It's always like two people,
three people. So I do think the idea
of having a small group of people coming
together that are not involved in the
day to day business as a management team
to deliberate and think about very key
decisions about which concern the whole
firm is, in my view,
irreplaceable. And I really do believe
in this. Now, what we do see,
however, is that some boards are
completely irrelevant. Some boards are a
source of inertia, and a
lot of the corporate governance
literature is about how do you make the
board really effective, then it comes
into diversity discussions and all of
this. I don't think that is really the
key. It really comes down to I'm
not a big fan of the diversity
in terms of stereotypical diversity to
say, oh, we should have, for example,
the Nordic countries in Europe have made
it the law that a certain number of
board members need to be female.
And right now it's really crazy because
they don't find enough women who are
prepared to go on the board even, and
who are qualified to go on the board.
And I
think that is the wrong way. I think
what you want is you want to constantly
self evaluate as a board to ensure that
you have the right expertise, the right
qualities on the board to steer the
company through its next challenges.
Got it? I see. So instead of a top down
mandated version of hey, this is the
kind of diversity you have, that should
actually be an internalized process
where you would internally be saying
like, hey, actually we don't have
representation from these groups that's
actually probably hampering our decision
making processes in these ways. Let's
intentionally create diversity to create
new cognitive capabilities on our board.
Does that culture that right, yeah. I
would put the emphasis on the cognitive
dimensions. Having said this, see, I'm
on the board of a company in Switzerland
which is quite big, has many
thousands of employees, is involved
around the globe, and I'm always
embarrassed when I look at the website
and you have four male wide
guys on the board, and this is a company
which is globally active.
We have a very important part of women
in our workforce.
And I don't think the board represents
this. So I do think the board has to
represent in some way also the world you
represent as a business. And I
think that board needs to change in
terms of diversity. But the diversity
shouldn't be just changed for the sake
of diversity. It should bring in, as you
rightly set the cognitive diversity at
the same time.
But we all know sometimes, and I
guess that's what the lawmakers imply,
the cognitive diversity is many times
related to the stereotypical diversity.
Unless they have anything else to add to
this, I do want to switch gears a little
bit because we have about ten minutes
left. And so something you're talking
about too is like you're envisioning a
very different version of what a board
looks like and get to the right slide.
So both for implementing free energy
governance from the perspective of being
inside a board, but then also within the
entire organization, it's a very
different way that especially a board
needs to operate. And I know that you're
on the board of several companies,
you're also a leader of several
companies as well. I'm kind of curious
how you think about the resistance that
you've encountered in implementing free
energy governance both within the board
and outside of the board as well. And
so, for example, I've had personal
experience with this as well, not
necessarily implementing free energy
governance, but also implementing things
that are less hierarchical, more of a
collective sense making process where
we're not top down deciding the
strategy, but we're more collectively
through a sense making process,
understanding what that purpose is.
And I've often found that can be very
disorienting for folks and a lot of fear
and uncertainty arises during that
process and a lot of resistance comes
during that process as well. I would
imagine that you would encounter similar
things implementing free energy
governance both within the board and
then within the larger organization. So
I'm kind of curious about types of
resistance that you found and how you've
kind of overcome that resistance in your
own organizations. Yeah, good, very good
question. Effectively it's a question or
this whole topic touches upon.
Let's be very precise. How do you make
actually free energy governance work in
an organization? Give me some very
precise tools. If I was interested now
in bridging the bottom and the top and
doing all these things, what should I
do? Give me a plan, give me some
inspiration. What other companies have
been doing. That's what I'm looking at,
putting together now through a research
project I'm undertaking to look
at companies. They may not call it free
energy governance, but they're dealing
precisely with those issues and what
they have been doing. But I want to and
so my answer will be twofold. I'm going
to answer first of all with your
question and then come actually to what
should be done because the two are kind
of related in a certain way. The
resistance I see in boards is
when you look at a board of directors,
it's a really very strange group of
people because most
of the time the recruitment of those
people is coming through connectivity.
I mean, of course, many times you do
have a headhunter saying like we need a
board member, can you find us somebody
interesting? And somebody comes and that
happens, I'm sure. I don't know what the
percentage is, but a fair share of board
positions are being done this way.
But then most of the time the board
members obviously know a lot of board
members and they say, look, this is a
great person, that person can join. The
board has these and these
qualifications. So what happens at the
end? That the board comes together a
little bit as a club. So there is in the
board, and by the way, there's a lot
of research which also says it's quite
important that the board members get
along very well, so that there's a good
climate on the board table.
It's a group of people who share a lot
of responsibility. What I have seen
over the time is that because of these
things and also because many times there
can be a lot of pressure on the board
taking decisions. In particular, at the
moment of crisis, there's an additional
communication challenge, visa vis the
public, visa vis the employee force. So
when you face these challenges, it
brings you obviously together. It's like
a family in the forest facing a
challenge to fight. You come even closer
together and you tend, in the
context of the board, you tend to become
a little bit introverted. And that's a
real problem because you start again,
it's skilled incompetence, it's
counterproductive to what you're
actually trying to achieve. You become
further removed from the rest of the
organization. You start inviting people
to make presentations, then you close
the doors again, you stay amongst
yourself, and I think you're going to be
hostage to a lot of blind spots, to a
lot of bias, toward a lot of agent
recognition, which nothing is always the
same. And you start becoming a little
bit too overconfident the way you can
take decisions. And my approach has been
and that's a problem. I do think that
every board, what I've just described
suffers to a certain degree from that
pathology. And that
makes it sometimes very difficult.
Because when you think about it, the
free energy governance framework is all
about how the board opens, how the board
communicates, how the board connects and
picks up the intelligence which is at
the bottom. And now we come to very
concrete measures of what you can do in
order to actually change this.
I have to say, to answer your question,
I have been practicing free energy
governance as a CEO, making that
the way I run the company and the way
the flow of information is generated,
the way decision power is distributed,
that the company is really empowered to
make judgment calls and execute them.
And that not the top becomes a
bottleneck. So I'm pretty good at that.
But I look at my board and my own
company, which is a pretty strong board
with very strong people, and strong
backgrounds, very serious business
people. I find it very difficult, for
example, to say, hey, on the website,
why don't you put next to your photo a
sentence which explains what's your
contribution to this company? Why are
you on the board? I think that's a
question everybody should answer. And I
think it makes all of a sudden a board
member much more accessible to the rest
of the organization. Because if somebody
says to me like they're responsible for
China and I'm involved in China, then
there is a guy or woman I should be
contacting and maybe share some ideas.
So I think that's a way of the board
opening up. I think a board member
should have on their website stating in
one sentence why they're on that board
and what their contribution is to the
company, from which angle they're
coming. That opens up second,
which is a great way and I've been
practicing this quite a bit, is creating
deep dives where you take people, very
junior people on a specific topic where
you believe these junior people middle
layer. People. Executive leadership
people together with selected board
members, not the whole board. Create a
deep dive around the topic. No
presentations. And just deep dive into a
topic, sharing actually what experiences
they are to advance the topic. And that
usually is an incredible experience. By
the end of the meeting, you don't know
who's a board member and who's a junior
guy because you don't come with this
like, come in here, make me a PowerPoint
presentation. I'm listening to you, and
then I will judge and come with all my
experience. You have to kill all of
this. The other element which I really
like, and I'm looking much deeper into
it and there are a number of big
companies who have been doing it, is
creating shadow boards. So now what
you're doing is you're looking ant the
closer to the front lines of really high
potential people talent who
form a board which is
holding a board meeting at the very same
time the main board is holding its board
meeting. They have more or less the same
documentation, the same agenda points,
and they take decisions as if they were
the board. They define agenda items
for the next board meeting. And all of a
sudden you're creating a group of people
closer to the front line who have to
delve into the topics. They must be
obviously senior enough that they can be
entrusted and that they are capable of
understanding all the issues and
assuming that role in a way of not just
looking at their domain, where they are
acting maybe, but looking at the whole
organization, because that's a challenge
for the board too. You have to really
understand how to relate and how to
respect a lot of interacting parts of a
company. And then you compare afterwards
the shadow board, what they have
discussed, how they have decided that's
a tremendous input of frontline
information of intelligence feeding into
the main board and possibly determining
future agenda items.
Oh, man. There's a lot of juicy, action
oriented things I would love to spend
the next 4 hours going into.
Unfortunately, we're at the top of the
hour, and so hopefully we can have you
back and we can go deeper into some of
these, especially the practice oriented
recommendations. Would love to explore
that more. But before we wrap up, when
we respectful of each other's time,
curious if anyone has any final closing
thoughts, comments, reflections,
questions before we wrap up.
I appreciate, Tyler and Bleu that you're
leading this series. We're going to
Continuum, the regular Jorge section
oriented videos keep a space open for
others to come in and range freely. And
Bijan, thanks again for joining your.
Welcome back anytime. Thank you, Bijan.
Yeah, thank you for inviting me. I'm
very honored that you took the book and
you're dedicating the time to it. I do
really believe, not because I wrote the
book, obviously it's a very theoretical
contribution, a more practical
correlation contribution should follow.
But I do believe. And I guess that's why
also Karl Friston decided to write The
Forward and also Connie Helford from
Dartmouth wrote The Forward is because I
do think this is the beginning of
changing things. And as I think Daniel
said it at the beginning, or I think
it was Bleu saying, this is something
Active Inference Lab Institute should be
looking at and being inspired by how you
design governance.
Thanks again. Till next time. Thank you.
Bye bye. Thanks for John. Bye. Thank
you. Thank you very much.